the chancellor seeking maximum political
cover today flanked by union and
business leaders
are you all united behind this plan as
he announces a less
generous scheme to try and get firms
through the next
phase of coronavirus i call the chance
of the exchequer
rishi sunak was explicit today that he
can't afford to go on funding emergency
coronavirus support at current levels
meaning now is the moment government
must start picking winners
and losers i'm announcing today the new
jobs support scheme the government will
directly support the wages of people
in work giving businesses who face
depressed demand
the option of keeping employees in a job
on shorter hours rather than making them
redundant yet while boris johnson talked
of restrictions lasting
up to six months rishi sunac goes
further
for at least the next six months the
virus and restrictions
are going to be a fact of our lives
our economy is now likely to undergo
a more permanent adjustment if the
outlook
is that bad labor is baffled as to why
the government isn't going further
we were really expecting more from the
chancellor today we were expecting
hopefully a wage support scheme that
would incentivize large numbers of
employers
to keep employees on we were expecting a
plan on retraining as well we had only
one word on training
from the chancellor today and we were
also expecting help for those businesses
that can't
take people back on now because they're
so strongly impacted by social
distancing
the biggest success for rishi sunak is
to get the stamp of approval of
both the cbi the biggest business group
and this is pretty extraordinary the tuc
the umbrella
union organization the biggest challenge
for the chancellor is not knowing
just how many jobs his new schemes will
save
particularly given the increased costs
on businesses
to keep staff in their posts from
november the treasury say the point of
today
is to support jobs how far does the
package they actually manage to do that
the problem he's got is that the design
of the scheme which is meant to
encourage firms to keep people on
part-time
in part-time work rather than letting
them go doesn't really do that because
of the amount that firms are asked to
contribute and so the danger is that the
people who lose are those
who are on the existing furlough scheme
but instead of going on to part-time
work lose their jobs entirely
the prime minister was 60 miles away
from westminster today visiting police
headquarters
in northampton to underline the
penalties for those breaking coronavirus
laws
you want to get out of the car or drive
it he acknowledged how difficult the
coming months will be
as a result of his chancellor's
decisions today we're
continuing to do everything we can to
support uh the workforce support jobs
livelihoods
uh throughout the crisis the chancellor
is being totally realistic with
people about the prospects of the of the
economy things will be
will be tough the prime minister
learning from experts how you cover a
wound
that looks very tight but it won't be
clear for some
months whether his chancellor helped
with the healing of the economy
or just disguised the problem for now
sam coates sky news